un viaje cargado de peligros pero no los
suficientes como para cesar en el
intento agarrados unos a otros para no
ser llevados por las fuertes corrientes
decenas de migrantes cruzan cada día el
río grande frontera natural entre méxico
y eeuu no yo estoy que lloró la verdad
de felicidad
nos gustó bastante llevamos hoy es el
día 26 que llevamos de travesía comprobé
hemos cruzado ya 6 países hemos sufrido
hemos sufrido porque hemos hemos tenido
momentos
que ya estamos que tiramos la toalla no
aguantamos se trata de una de las
fronteras más mortíferas del mundo como
lo demostró el reciente fallecimiento de
los 53 migrantes asfixiados dentro de un
camión en san antonio texas la
organización mundial de las migraciones
estima que el 58 por ciento del total de
migrantes fallecidos en 2021 perdieron
la vida en este cruce ni siquiera el
endurecimiento de los controles
militares en las fronteras frena el
tránsito masivo de personas muchas
viajan ayudadas por coyotes o
traficantes a los que pagan hasta diez
mil dólares el hecho que haya una visión
o una política de control y de
endurecimiento en las fronteras lo único
que hace es primero que sea más costoso
el cruce y eso quién termina ganando son
los grupos del crimen detrás de estas
redes de tráfico de personas por un lado
porque pueden cobrar más caro entre más
difícil sea pasar más caro pueden cobrar
la región vive un flujo migratorio
recortes de américa latina y
centroamérica asia estados unidos el
gobierno mexicano reportó un incremento
del 89 por ciento interanual sólo en el
primer trimestre de 2022